what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
sit Downs with pearl where I sit down
with some guests from my show and we
talk about
um different stuff today I have a
special guest Brittany Renner hi
the man the woman the man the legend
welcome to the show thank you for having
me thank you for coming so
um
today we are going to talk about
you are one of the most notorious people
in the manosphere okay and I think that
I kind of represent that average viewer
that you know knows a bit about you but
not the whole story so I was hoping to
start from the beginning
how did this reputation come about
and do you feel like it is deserved
I do feel that it's deserved because
what I've come to understand is that I
have misrepresented myself for a very
long time and I would say that my
villain origin story was
I had first moved to LA in 2014
was linking up with someone after my
breakup with a guy I was with four years
and TMZ put out an article and claimed
that I got that I said I was pregnant by
Colin Kaepernick right wait okay so
you're with a guy for four years break
up from high school um from College from
college you said 18
um 18 what you moved at 18. I moved I
moved to LA in 2014. oh 2014. yes okay
and how old were you I I think maybe 21
22. um and you were dating Colin
Kaepernick at the time I wouldn't
hooking up whatever Lincoln Lincoln
sneaky Lincoln at the time
um
and
with that
um
they had photoshopped a picture I had
like posted him for like my man crush
Monday this is like Instagram a long
time ago when there was woman crush
Wednesdays man crushed Monday you
remember that yeah so um so I had posted
him and I put like Perfection and then I
added him and again why I posted on my
Instagram great question
um but someone had photoshopped the
image Media Takeout I don't know if
you've ever heard of them but they had
posted it and then TMZ ran the story and
I felt like from that moment on
I was labeled a villain and you have to
understand I was in a relationship for
four years like most people know the
white guy that I used to date uh we used
to post together he's the reason I got
into fitness
um and I was already labeled a villain a
[ __ ] and was accused of something that
I didn't do and so I'm what did you not
do so they they were so I had put
Perfection at his his username and they
Photoshopped it to say preggers at his
username so they were like this girl
claims that she's they were saying that
you claimed that you were yes okay and I
I actually looked it up I have a
screenshot too I looked it up last night
to see if the article was still up and
it's still up so at that moment in time
I realized that
even though by per Society standards I
was someone who you know low body count
and I had not talked to any famous guy
I'd never been around I had a big
following
an ideal situation right starting out in
Hollywood already labeled a [ __ ] a liar
a gold digger so I when I think about
how my origin story began like my
villain origin story it was that it was
like I haven't even done anything and
I'm already misunderstood so I think as
time progressed
I really just try to fake it till I
could make it and inside I never like
especially in high school like growing
up I never felt like I was just top tier
beautiful because I just wasn't you know
I was growing into myself I always had
really bad skin over fried my hair
always wearing extensions never feeling
pretty as even my natural self like
where I am now
um
so
how I started even like posting videos
and having and being maybe like overly
sexual was because I was like I want to
feel like this bad [ __ ] so again I've
only seen like clips of you I've seen a
couple car rants okay okay so I'm just
gonna be see the pepper car rants I Know
You released a book yeah in 2018 yeah
and I know that
um I saw the stuff you did with fresh
and fit PG academics like those little
interviews here and there yeah so when
we go back to 20 you said 24 yeah 2014
when you're in La so then did you start
dating Kaepernick
um I would just say that I started like
dating period like I kind of just opened
it up it's not like we were exclusive
whatever
um so I will say that the the villain
came about was I never I was a small
town girl from Mississippi like to even
be in certain rooms with people where it
was unheard of I never thought these
these guys would even know I existed so
I felt like there was still that like
starry-eyed element where here
I didn't know what I was doing I felt
like I had been like thrown into Disney
World so to speak right like the world
is at your fingertips and again all
these high value men are now seeking you
and again I'm a girl from Ocean Springs
Mississippi people don't even probably
know where that is
um so I think that's where
over sexualizing myself and really
pitching into that that's like the whole
bad [ __ ] like wanting to feel like
something I didn't so were you were you
sleeping with a lot of these guys and
then like posting stuff on social media
okay no actually like I said besides
that post where I had you know made him
my man crush Monday I didn't even say
that we were dating you know I never
it's not like I was like hey look at me
here I am at a game or here I am at his
house like it wasn't that it was just
that's how everything started out okay
so I'm just trying to understand because
there's one one article that's a one-off
right yeah like you know I you can kind
of recover from one article in my
opinion anyway but there there was more
that happened in between what happened
next
I've well I mean because I'm saying this
because this is literally on like TMZ so
after that
um
when I was talking to him I kind of
moved on because I'm like whatever your
robotic we move on
um
kind of got caught up with Trey songs
oh TMZ was like asking him questions
about because like my fitness group was
like the Fitbit Army so then I was
linked to him right so then that's kind
of where it just started to so then you
started it wouldn't work out I would
move on okay and then yeah like I I
especially when I first got on social
media it was a different place right
um early 20s
guys from all over I mean it was just I
would entertain one at a time though
that was like my thing so like when I'm
done with you I'm gonna move on and then
it just became so unsuccessful
relationships and I moved on okay so it
was just like you were linked with
rapper Entertainer a lot of my show was
public and I and I feel like that's
where a lot of people are like she's a
[ __ ] but it's like there's articles
where someone took a picture of me at
the movie theater with a guy that's out
of my control so
I would say now
um you know when you've kind of figured
out how the world works you try to be a
bit more mindful about who you even step
out with but you can't control if people
take pictures of you that's were you
posting any of these guys yourself so
you never post no because we weren't we
weren't exclusive right you know what I
mean like I'm gonna post somebody that's
my man again I'm a 21 22 year old posted
that man crush Monday that's obviously
very childish right but all these other
guys they did not I didn't post them on
my page
so and so then basically
um because you're linked to all these
different guys publicly how publicly
they're now that's when the reputation
started yeah
then so this is this is where so then
the book comes tell me 2018 yeah and
from what I know I haven't read the book
okay what I know of the book is that you
basically exposed a lot of people in the
book this is just what what I've heard
you
basically
all the stuff you've been doing you put
in the book and while you might not have
said their names exactly was pretty easy
for people to figure out who they were
okay well I didn't expose anyone
um my book was like a 25 year old Memoir
basically and I didn't list all of these
sexapades so there were seven seven
people okay fake names
um
seven relationships like situationships
whatever you want to call them and what
I learned from that so there was a lot
of my book was about sharing my story
and being accountable the most like
salacious stories or sex they weren't
even in there because it wasn't a lot of
these guys it was a typical if you want
I'm sorry I said you could tell now if
you want yeah I mean I'm just kidding
yes I mean it's just kind of like that
was never my intention my book never had
ill intent now again I know the
salacious marketing was intentional
because I knew people were thinking I'm
gonna it's like it's like a thumbnail
yeah like yeah it's clickbait like yeah
look at all these guys are here yeah
because I know you're gonna [ __ ] buy
the book but when people actually read
it any person who's read my book is like
wait this is completely different than
how you pitched it and it really is a
book about accountability so
um those seven people really helped
we're like pivotal moments for me so
again I took what came with the
salacious marketing and again
misrepresenting myself is just that
right so you have to accept what comes
behind that so I wanted to sell a book I
had no problem with doing you know using
my tactics to get copies sold and what
came with that is she's not trustworthy
she's a [ __ ] and that's all she cares
about is money she's just a quick money
grab like she's the girl that cannot be
trusted and I understand that if you've
never read my book it's like what I'm
saying doesn't even make sense because
like you would actually have to
physically read it that's why the book
is called judge this cover you're gonna
do that anyways there are people that
just took little Snippets from each
chapter
and judge me off of that you're talking
about
this guy I was talking about spitting in
his mouth or paying for flights that was
one that was circulating on Twitter I I
talked about how I paid for my own
flights so it's like I'm such a gold
digger why am I pay for my flights so
there's just things in there that I felt
like people did not want to understand
me you didn't open the book so your
opinion doesn't [ __ ] matter about the
book read it and then tell me how you
feel about me you know that's kind of
how I feel with that so so then you
write the book were any of the people
that were in the book mad that you wrote
the book
um the conversations I've had because
there's maybe like two or two guys in
there that I have not spoken to right
the other five I've had conversations
with since um one of the people at
actually asked me to Market them as one
of the people in it they didn't mind
that
um other guys in my life just in general
were asked like why they weren't in it
they were like sad right
um but most of the guys I have a good
relationship with like we're still cool
so they understood that that was my
experience that was my perspective and
that was that I mean there was one
chapter I spoke to recently he um he was
like I was just waiting for you to say
my name so I could have sued you for
everything right and I'm just like well
that wasn't my plan like I wasn't trying
to hurt you but he was like I understood
your perspective and I get he said you
didn't you didn't lie in it so
okay so none of the guys had hurt
feelings over the book no okay okay well
so that that seems because I kind of
thought
um like from what I had heard is that
some of the guys maybe weren't happy
they were in the book I'm sure they
weren't but I think the people that
weren't happy about it the two that I'm
thinking of in my mind I just haven't
spoken to them okay you know the other
five I did so
you know okay I don't know I don't know
I don't know how they would feel so you
don't think like because I'm just
thinking this is I just know how the
guys are gonna see it like you're
choosing to publicly link with these
people and maybe you didn't want it to
be public but it's like if you're making
a choice to go after the Like Rappers
athletes like that sort of thing of
course people are gonna call you a hoe
and that's fine yeah and you know that's
the thing you don't shy away from that
yeah but it goes back to my original
question whether you think it's earned
or not or it's like misrepresenting you
or not well I think there's that I have
misrepresented myself because again I
bundle of Britney is like her own that's
like
a Frankenstein I have created right and
that's like a fraction even just the
time we've spent the past few days
together probably very different than
what you've seen online you know so
that's what I have used to get views and
get clicks and I've realized that I
don't have to do that anymore so that's
where the misrepresentation comes in but
again
a hoe and I guess is in this sphere
right is someone who has sex with
multiple guys okay well then that's not
a term I'm gonna shy away from I've had
sex with multiple guys now I'm not gonna
take that word and be like I'm So
Unworthy I'm a [ __ ] it just is what it
is like that's how they want to
distinguish what category women fall
under I got no problem with that that's
fine okay okay I've had sex multiple
guys didn't work out and moved on you
know okay so so that that part you don't
necessarily feel like was misrepresented
based on how the guys would see how they
would yeah how they would see it okay
okay so then next next this is this is
where I heard of you first okay let's
talk about PJ okay so you you do the
book as PJ next or is there something in
between
a meaning like when we met yeah
um yeah so we met
he he actually came to my hosting
um in 2018 May of 2018 so that's like
basically where we first met it was not
romantic like it literally had a job
there he's like hey I'm gonna come by
okay cool
um
I he invited me to his his game at UK
February 2019. right so we met
um I went back for my birthday so I went
to two Kentucky games and that's when we
first started talking like after my
birthday we talked almost every single
day and I was aware like he's younger
than me I always had a lot of judgment
towards guys who are younger than me
because I'm like you're younger than me
how can you handle me you know right
um but I always felt like PJ saw me for
me
and that is the [ __ ] god honest truth
um
it makes me sad even thinking about it
because like
I don't know you just think people get
you and it just doesn't work out so
that's why I overlooked some of those
things like the age oh he's about to be
in the NBA I overlooked that because I
felt like oh my God I finally have a guy
who doesn't judge me who sees me for me
and like accepts it and understands my
value so I felt like he was somebody
that like deserved all my time and
attention and
you know it just didn't end up working
out long term so and how old was he when
it started how old were you because this
is the the next 20. I've got a million
questions about the age they get I'm so
glad you brought it out you grooming
like they they said because
what just to give context to the viewers
at home if you guys don't know anything
about Brittany I saw a video of you
where you were in the car saying this is
basically how to you can kind of get a
kid off of an NBA player yeah and it's
really easy because these guys don't
wear condoms and it's something to that
effect so then a couple years later when
you you have a kid off an NBA player it
looks it's not a good look and
especially that he's a lot younger than
you so what what did you feel like was
misrepresented there
so to give a little bit more context to
the video too
um especially I think I made this video
in 2018 and I was in my car ranting you
know like I always do and people were
saying that you know you're a gold
digger you're this and you're that and
my way to defend myself this is what was
that one you also said that you pay for
your own flights too I was just I'm
trying to I I would have to go to my
archive and play the video in its
entirety to be able to confirm that okay
because there were other times I talked
about paying for my flights
um but in that video I was saying that
if I really was a gold digger
I could have several kids by now and so
it was an attempt to make a group of
people look bad and I made myself look
even worse because I'm like what are you
guys talking about I'm a gold digger
these athletes don't use condoms I could
have a baby by then right it aged
horribly right and I don't and I don't
ever try to deny that and I don't do
apology tours it is what it is I said
what I said like that was my truth that
was my experience the people that I was
encountering it's not even like an
athlete thing a lot of guys don't wear
condoms but it was surprising to me that
people of such high status were a little
bit more Reckless right
um and because we think they have so
much to lose yeah I guess that that's
weird yeah that's exactly what it is
right it's like why would you why do you
trust me right and then as a young
person and you're not even young person
because so in your head you were saying
like [ __ ] the haters I could have a kid
none of these people if you wanted to
catch a kid by an NBA player it's really
easy because they're dumb right so
that's where that the context of that
video right and then I met PJ like we
started talking when he was 20 years
years old we have a six year age Gap
okay so you're 26. yeah 20. I'm thinking
I'm 26 I'm thinking
20 year olds are pretty immature but I'm
telling you when I met him I just felt
like and like genuinely yeah he had an
old soul that's how I felt about him so
a lot of people tried to
like
I don't know I feel like they try to
tell me how I felt and like my
intentions and it's like I know the
truth like I know the person that I was
sitting across from at BJ's when we had
our first date in Kentucky and Lexington
like you can't you can't tell me that
you know I personally think 20 is old
enough to make your own decisions I put
myself when I was 20 and I'm thinking
you can't really be groomed at 20 years
old but for some reason I feel like back
then they said that you something about
you met him in high school I did not
even know he existed okay I didn't like
and honestly did you see him play in
high school never okay I don't but
that's what I'm saying the 200 000 a
month the meeting him when he was in
high school again like even when I first
was like I met PJ when I went to
Kentucky
um I was talking to someone who played
on the nuggets at the time and it was
something that I kind of had a history
with and when I met PJ and we had that
connection I immediately cut the guy
from the Nuggets off you see what I'm
saying so like I own [ __ ] going I did
not know he existed when he was in
[ __ ] high school what I'm pulling
Heavy Hitters what am I worried about a
[ __ ] kid in high school for but
that's where people just make up their
own [ __ ] so it's like well I can't
really
you guys are gonna say what the [ __ ] you
want to say all I can do is sit here and
tell you the truth you know
so so 20 you guys start talking when
when did you get pregnant
he I got pregnant and you were with him
for how long
um were you guys dating or were you like
linking no we were we were exclusive
when I got pregnant um so we talked from
February 2019 to February 2020. now
I don't know what he was doing with who
he was doing it with whatever
um but we started dating February 2020.
I left California
April of 2020 and I moved in with him
um I had my own place where I was
staying in his apartment we were
basically kind of living together
already he asked me to move in with him
in the summertime I got pregnant August
2020. so we had been a year and a half
at least familiar with one another but
exclusive probably those six eight
months six to eight months yeah and did
you say it was the child planned yeah I
mean my son is Paul Jermaine Washington
III okay like he has his father's name
sat down and said I want to have a yes
and I was on birth control for 10 years
because I never wanted to go through an
abortion that was just me personally I'm
like well if I can prevent it and I'd
rather be safe and again like I'm hot
I'm hopping I got [ __ ] going on I'm
definitely not trying to have anybody's
child right so I got off birth control
and there was a conversation got off
birth control I got pregnant so it
wasn't some oops I came in you and you
got pregnant like no it was I want a
family I want a child we're gonna get
married has PJ ever done like interviews
on this no I don't know I'm just curious
would he say the same thing yeah yeah
okay I mean the truth is the truth
you know I mean there's some things like
again we can share perspective right but
the facts of the matter are
he was planned so that can't that he
can't even be disputed you know um I
always thought PJ was like kind of quiet
and more to himself so I don't actually
see him ever really doing an interview
like I feel like now he's
when we broke up how everything panned
out was like very public and out of
character from what I knew of him
um but I don't foresee him doing an
interview I don't
okay so you guys you guys break up or no
you're together
um tell me how how did you guys split up
and you you can be as detailed or not
detailed as you want you don't have to
go into okay
um
there were some things like so I had
never gone through anybody's bone in
like my because at the time I was 28
right um girl you were dealing with
athletes I never went to anybody's phone
never except PJs okay okay yep because I
felt like if I have to go through your
phone yeah I already have my answer
right and I'm not doing that I'm not
playing [ __ ] detective right so I
went through his phone again this was
the summer like you know a few months
before I got pregnant found some stuff
in this phone I didn't like nothing
confirmed I mean you're just
entertaining [ __ ] like okay
I had never been cheated on that I knew
of right and I found out stuff that like
he had sex with someone in the beginning
of our relationship but this is in March
you slept with this girl I found out
July
I didn't already moved my whole life
I'm already here
okay well you know you moved from L.A
yeah because I moved from Woodland Hills
I had a condo at Woodland Hills and I
moved all of my all my whole life to
Charlotte North Carolina to be with him
right
so I found out some stuff I'm like okay
you [ __ ] this girl in March all right
I love you and I know what you've seen
growing up
I've never forgiven anyone because I've
never caught anyone cheating on me but
like I understand your family Dynamics
so I can
I choose to understand and to forgive
you and so
one of my best friends
when we were talking about how we were
like basically trying to get pregnant
she was like do you think it's a good
idea because you just found out all this
stuff right like the voice of reason
right and she's like I don't think
that's a good foundation and I was just
like no I trust who I'm with like I get
it like we've talked about it I
understand and he is younger than me
right he's younger than me
I I'm gonna try I'm gonna try this I'm
gonna I've never done this but I'm just
gonna try to overlook it and move on so
with that knowledge again this is where
I take accountability too
I saw behaviors I saw red flags and I
still chose to move forward and it's
because I loved him I don't know I just
I believed in him and I guess that's
where I'm a foolish woman because I just
chose to believe in him yeah girls La La
Land respectfully yeah it's just like
and we talked about this a little bit
before I'm just thinking like an NBA
player faithful
I've seen him I I've said I've said this
before but I'm set the D3 level D3 D3
the nerve
around campus and it's like that's the
division three basketball I'm thinking
division one has to be Madness the NBA
has to be Madness yeah at first hand
you've been dealing with these guys for
like a decade you know it's Madness it
is and that's just where I kind of just
take it on the chin and I'm like I
believed in someone and it just didn't
work out and I know and he knows the
conversations in the cons in the
consistency that I thought you know like
this is more than enough for me to trust
it
um
I just believed in him and I again I can
accept my responsibility in that for
overlooking certain things that really
should have I should have paid more
attention to why didn't you ever look
for like just a normal guy with like a
nine to five
because it's just guys will always say
like pay attention to what they do not
what they say
and okay and it's like a lot of times
we'll complain about getting like
cheated on or something right and then
you know we Overlook the nine to five
guy who won't
I would say that I mean the my first
boyfriend I met in college he was
regular guy and I loved him to death
um I had I had dated a lawyer during
that during that span to broke up with
who college guy um I broke up with him
because it got abusive on both ends but
this is this is just just from the guy's
perspective like they're they're gonna
be like okay well that was the guy who
wouldn't cheat but you dumped him well
it got to a place where he was very kind
I mean he was condescending and
emotionally really abusive and then it
got to a place where you're pushing me
now you're bruising on my arms and now
I'm putting my hands on you because I'm
trying to defend myself and I just felt
like the respect was gone
um it had nothing to do with whether he
cheated or not it was we are we are very
toxic together and I do not foresee us
moving past this like I feel like once
this is me once that respect is lost for
whatever reason and then I all put your
hands on each other it has to end
because there's only one way it's going
to end it only gets progressively worse
in my opinion in my experience I'm not
trying to find out either you're putting
your hands on me doing all the other
stuff I don't want to see what you're
capable of did you file a police report
at all or no no
because again it's just like from
like a lot of times we'll say these
things about guys but it's like it's the
question it's like me if I'm getting
punched in the face oh I wasn't getting
punched in the face it was more so you
were like bruising my arms and pushing
me down and little stuff like that and I
I know I if he would have punched me in
the face that would have also be a
different thing I've never been hitting
or punched anything ever so yeah I feel
like it was leading up to being punched
in the face
um but bruises on my arms to me is a
little more than enough and then you
never hit first I slapped him yeah okay
okay but you would agree that's like
mutually abusive no that's what I said I
said yeah I never said oh my God no like
it got to a place where I'm like all
right now I'm about to put my hands on
YouTube and that's the thing like I
think
a lot of times you actually do you know
agree with like a lot of the stuff I say
which is interesting why
um
level but no you actually are
more bass than I thought you were gonna
be I I like what you talk about I think
that it's foreign to me because or I
would say probably a lot of females as
well because
I I can honestly say I speak for myself
because I want to speak for everybody
but I never thought about it I never
thought about how men feel I never
thought about biologically speaking what
makes sense I never thought about how in
marriage you know especially if the man
makes more that it's kind of a shitty
contract on there and I know business
that doesn't make sense you know unless
we're signing prenups right so it's just
like
since I've been listening to your
contents and I knew I was going to get
on here I started to like you a lot more
right it's easy to just kind of take a
clip from you and be like oh my God she
said she's not I personally like you
like your personality is why I got on a
seven hour flight and I knew that even
though I may not agree and I think that
and not even about agreeing even though
I may not just limit it to just that
like that perspective I respect it and I
think it's true there's a there's really
not a lot of stuff I think is untrue and
I just have told you even when we were
speaking off camera that
this is a newer mentality I don't know
what this mentality would mean to
society as a whole we kind of talked
about the arranged marriages and um uh
what would that mean for society as a
whole right and I think I can't remember
the verbage you used when we were
talking about how um the arranged
marriages and how women um if we had
dreams and stuff we wanted to explore on
what what that outcome would look like
you said that I don't remember the term
you used though I don't know okay
um but no it's like I I get it and all I
can do is just be honest about
like this is the expression that
I like that is coded within me and I am
willing to accept the consequences that
comes behind it so I don't ask for
um
people to look at me through a different
lens
um I'm just kind of here to be myself
and just showcase another perspective
that's really it
so
I'm thinking so you do the
looking back was there anything that you
would do differently and is there a
different advice that you would give to
a 20 year old girl that has the same
opportunities that you did
I think the biggest thing that I would
want to do differently is what were the
athletes
well I will say
I have to be honest with myself because
I think it's easy to take the cliche
route and say like I would do nothing
differently now from the
wisdom I have acquired no I would not
change this wisdom for a clean slate and
that's just the god honest truth but I
will say to 20 year olds and even to my
20 year old self
I hate how I allowed myself to just be
like used up I meant
and that came from a lack of self-worth
I did not understand my value that I was
born with I didn't and I gave
again people look at sex differently but
sex is spiritual unification at the end
they don't care how you spin it it's
spiritual women okay that's okay
whatever okay fine for women it's
spiritual unification
and people that I shared my body with
when I think about my list
it's repulsive because they didn't
deserve it
but that was an outcome of me
discounting my worth
and
it's disgusting
um
I hate even having that
spiritual tie in any type of way but
yeah I would absolutely change sexually
High move around and not even
necessarily because of like the societal
outcome it's more so
it makes you like feel yeah it doesn't
feel good
knowing that you gave a sacred part of
you to a man that looked at sex with you
as taking a piss
that's not fulfilling it's disgusting to
think about and I feel like I've beat
myself up every single day for my
decisions and what people say about me
online holds no candle to what I've told
myself on a daily basis like there's
I've been called worse by better and
that better be me like I've talked down
to myself and I felt like I was unworthy
for a very long time and I would say
this is more of a recent awareness like
in the past year
um
where I'm like
Britney you were always enough
like you never had to seek validation
outside of you you never had to look
that far and um that's what I would
would tell myself I would and try to
tell women
you should really think about who you're
laying down with like and that's that is
a more traditional view but it's like
sex is not even worth it if they don't
give a [ __ ] about you they don't care
about you they have no desire to they
don't want to know your favorite color
they don't give a [ __ ] so why do you
want them over top of you again that's
come from
feeling used up and sometimes that's why
the used Goods comments they sting
because you know what
there are times I felt like that I feel
like the old toy or sorry the new toy
that now is unexciting and put away in a
box so I just have to accept what I've
done and move forward with this
awareness and just know that okay
the guy that I that most likely that I'm
not looking for a husband I'm looking
for my husband and there's a difference
that guy is going to be a very small
percentage and I'm okay with that I'm at
peace and I'm at peace with the things
I've done but I will say moving for like
talking to any girl to you and you know
whoever's listening it's like you really
should think about why you're doing what
you're doing what like really think
about why am I attracting that what part
of me is resonating with a guy like that
if you have all these complaints about
him what's resonating with him really
analyzing what you're doing that's what
I would suggest so why don't because in
my head like
why wouldn't you avoid this if you could
go back you wouldn't avoid the
situations because you I thought in the
beginning you said that like you
wouldn't change it because of the wisdom
you've acquired but to me it's like oh
my God if I if I knew what I know now
like I probably I probably would have
waited till I was married no I I get
that I think that
I have a very influential voice and I
have grown to be a voice for women who
have gone through what I've gone through
and experienced what I've experienced
and
although I again I can't speak for the
majority because my situation still
isn't even average right and I'm aware
of that but my voice is important just
like your voice is important and that's
why I don't I would not want to change
anything because what again I don't know
what my this is a very tough spot to be
in right because you're figuring it out
you have people who are also trying to
figure it out and it's like I'm needed
in this space because I my voice guides
those women that you guys talk about
right so that's why I wouldn't change it
because there's a greater picture even
in my like I told you my last
relationship had the Bentley had the
house had the kid
and it wasn't enough okay so it may be a
small percentage of us women who feel
this way but those I feel like that's
the voice that I'm I represent oh no oh
no there's a large percentage okay okay
well I mean I mean I mean I don't know
you know they're predicting that 45 of
women will be single and childless by
2030. so much so that big banks are
investing in like cat food wine like
things that go with like single women
wow yeah okay so I feel like my voice
does matter navigate through this space
so it's like
uh it's like again it's such a small
percentage of men that you're like
looking for now I know yeah
yeah um how do you want to navigate that
like moving forward
um do you give me do you even want a
date like right now because you you um
so I know some people when their kids
are young like just don't want to date
how do you like feel about that
um I think it has more to do with
where I'm at
um emotionally and
it's not even like a jaded thing right
it's more of
I know my value
I can talk to I can have one
conversation with a guy now
and I know exactly what he's about
so most of the guys that have presented
themselves in front of me just want to
[ __ ] me
I'm not interested in that
and I'm going to keep my I'm going to
keep an open mind and I'm going to keep
an open heart but I know by how a man
approaches me how he speaks to me I know
that there's that that he wants more
with me it is just I know so that's
where I'm like I'm not going on dates
right now I'm not talking I don't have
somebody that we talk every few days
every day
I have no masculine energy besides like
my family our family friend Jerry
um I have no masculine energy
in my in my in my ear in my bubble I
don't because I think
I focused on men and just dick in
general for a very long time
and now I'm I'm just gonna get to the
business
um I understand that the window the
percentage it's it's it's changed a lot
from when I was 22. so all I can do is
kind of equip myself financially take
advantage of the opportunities I have
now to set myself up because I can't
rely on
a man and come someone coming to save me
I can only save myself now so that's why
I'm dating is not a focal point but I'm
not like turning guys away that that
actually want to get to know me like the
real me not just want to [ __ ] me and say
all the right things and [ __ ] me because
I can see through that too so I just use
discernment now where I'm like no guys
even really try to talk to me like or I
should say um no guys that it's like I
don't know no no of course of course
guys no no I'm saying of course those
guys in my damn like random people yeah
but guys that I would be interested in
they there's really nobody trying to
talk to me like that and that's okay
that's fine would you date a guy that's
a normal nine okay would you date a guy
makes 40 000 per year and he's not hot
he's just like all right
average guy
average guy he has a little a little
weird he's like skinny you know little
beer belly
no no
I take care of myself I'm in the gym
four to five times a week
um at whatever his salary is to me I
feel like I still want to be attracted
to the person that I'm with and 45 000
well you could be in the gym gym
membership's 20 a month so if I'm again
I had a kid a year and a half ago I like
damn good so it's like I would want
someone who takes care of their body so
the the beer bellies work on where you
lost me it wasn't even really the money
thing it's like the attractive is like
dead in the face but jacked 40 000 a
year
no I don't like what I'm looking at and
then like especially two as they get
older like I like the salt and pepper
like they get sexier like I don't want
to date someone that I'm not attracted
to would you date someone like 20 30
years older
30 years older
he salt and pepper and fine
probably he's okay
because it's just like even when girls
say they're like breaking down their
standards like do we really
I think I I think I'm like you know
percent of men most women find
unattractive what
not not just okay unattractive okay 80
you probably find 80 of men unattractive
so even if like just and that's why I
say like even if you find a guy
attractive like you just think he's fine
that means other girls think he's fine
that's top 20 of men
and again and it kind of just puts us in
the same predicament where it's like
through our 20s like this this is what
the guys are complaining about it's like
okay through our 20s we're gonna sleep
around with the the rappers the
entertainers and maybe like you know
most girls I I would say I know the
manosphere says differently don't don't
have access to the guys you would access
to right but it could be like the town
rapper the town like whatever whatever
it was right yeah and those guys will
never commit and if they do commit
they'll probably cheat and then we come
at 30 and say take me now maybe with a
kid from someone yeah and it's like the
guy comes in and feels like he's like
settled for because the guys he really
wanted were in your 20s
and it's kind of like what you're saying
is kind of reiterating this because you
just said now like you don't have the
guys you want in your DMs anymore
correct but this is how it's meant to be
because a lot of people have
villainized me and I've played into that
actually I'm gonna say people have
villainized me and I have villainized
myself because it's like well instead of
fighting against it and you know uh I
don't know trying to convince people I'm
actually a good-hearted person it's
easier just be the villain
um so I do feel like the villain element
is a lot of I would say more so what
guys fear right because they're thinking
she's gonna hurt me she's gonna write
about me she's gonna this
um so to be honest I wasn't meant to be
with any of those guys in my 20s like
there it wasn't a match like there's
nobody then that I'm like I wish they
would take me seriously now no like they
I like them the same reason they like me
I'm trophy [ __ ] to them and they're
basically trophy dick to me we both got
what we wanted I mean essentially we
want to have sex that worked I mean yeah
you have sex and you maybe want to start
being in a relationship but you don't I
didn't [ __ ] know them like that
there's a lot of guys I didn't really
know on that level to even it makes
sense so it's not even like you were
saying um
I'm trying to think the sentence you
said before we started this conversation
though I was this this topic
um so so it's not even that I'm like oh
I wish I had those options it's just
more so like that [ __ ] was shallow
anyways everything was shallow about it
like you didn't really want to get to
know me from me yeah but anyway that's
like the woman's point of view you know
what I mean like but they didn't want to
get if they wanted to get to know me
from me
it'd been a little different no but I'm
saying like from the men's point of view
it's gonna be and this is just you know
again what what the guys are saying yeah
but it's like yeah you made all those
like you let all those guys hit for free
and now I gotta do all this well it's
not even I don't even look at it as well
you did it for free because I'm not a
prostitute like and I'm not a glorified
escort right and that's that might not
be how you look at it but this is that's
crazy this is this is just like this is
how men see it it's like it's like okay
blessing
you have you you took your girl on dates
right
yeah how would you feel how would you
feel if you took her on let's say five
dates before you hit I don't know what
y'all did I'm not and then you found out
that your Bob down the street
without taking her own [ __ ]
like it hurts it's like another man's
ego no that's fine and it hurts it's not
even it's not insecure
secure it just like I
mean but that's what that's where I have
to come in and say
okay like I'm not saying your ego
shouldn't be hurt I'm saying you're not
somebody that
is even like we're not on each other's
radar so the man that I want can't can't
care about who the [ __ ] I went on it who
I did what with and that's a small
percentage so that's why it's like him
saying that he's allowed to feel that
way I mean that's fine like you're not
on my right I think the point is like
all men think like this I I'm not gonna
generalize all I just can't like we can
say majority but I'm not gonna
generalize and say all because it's like
what my biggest issue is is like once
you hit a certain age you're no good
okay so so women we get we hit 30 and
we're basically useless to society
to most men that's how they're going to
feel that
way it's again we it's the men that we
want that feel that way because those
men have options eighty percent of men
women find unattractive
those men will date 30 year olds they'll
date single mothers they'll do all of it
it's it's the 20 of men that we want
when they say Okay single mom or no
single mom I'm gonna pick no single mom
because it's just less headache no if if
I could pick a 22 year old or a 32 year
old I'm gonna pick a 22 year old it's
not fun it's not to say nobody gets
through but just like on a balance of
probabilities no and that's fine I just
think I think I think the men sometimes
get frustrated with us because they feel
like we've been sold this fairy tale
that's just not real and these men are
not real
like to that and that's that's where
they come in and say like women are
delusional for like wanting these things
I mean and from their perspective that's
valid that I don't have to
like if that's how however whatever
percentage men you want to say that's
how they feel you're saying all I'm
saying I'm not I'm not gonna categorize
the things
I'll give you five percent okay five
percent okay well then I'm only
concerned about the five like I I have
no like I'm not I'm not Jehovah's
Witness I'm not here to convert you guys
shouldn't think this way about me you
should see me as this see my value I
don't I don't know I'm not saying like
there's nothing you can do yeah you're
where you're at you can't undo the men
you slept with yeah you have you guess
what it is you you you have you have a
child so you can't undo any of that
there's no point in harping about it and
I think that's the point you generally
try to make yeah is that I accept the
repercussions of my decisions good bad
or indifferent but my only point is I'm
just trying to like let you know this is
how the men see it and this is what
they're talking about in The Red Pill I
get it
um
okay what were your biggest
disagreements with me before you met me
biggest disagreements
or anything on the show that you've that
you've disagreed with that I said I
think there were maybe three things okay
um the first well I had only watched one
video on your Instagram okay um because
I I didn't want to do too deep of a dive
just yet right and it was the women
aren't entitled to safety
um and I think it's triggering because
like
you think of like well why can't like
why do I have to fear going down on a
dark alley right but then when you
actually think about it none of us are
entitled to safety so that statement is
actually true so um
that was one thing so I kind of went
through my own thought process we moved
forward I don't even know so many people
triggered over that one yeah because
it's like you do want to be like well
why can't I go down an alley at one in
the morning well you
know but you know whatever but I think
the other thing we had um on the show
again I don't disagree with that okay
maybe the the fat comments aren't that
nice or the I can't I can't say it I I
would say that a large Majestic I don't
I don't think they're nice
um
I get they started though okay but I
mean so I get you trying to defend
yourself and like when somebody says
something mean to you or again if
someone's not nice to you you're gonna
be not nice back so
even from your perspective I still get
it it's like you attack me well I'm
gonna you're gonna hit me I'm going
below the boat you're going low I'm
going to hell you know what I mean so
even even though I don't agree
I understand because if you're gonna
talk about me I'm gonna talk about
YouTube right and I think the only thing
during
um our our talk with Andrew that I think
I got maybe a little hyper was when we
were talking about the child support
stuff
um and that's just because that is a
close to home topic and it is a very
um it is a topic that is to me is talked
about a lot and people who don't have a
[ __ ] kid who aren't going through
this process the lawyers the custody
child support all that stuff you don't
have a [ __ ] clue you know so
every law every state is has different
laws so I think that was the only thing
where I felt kind of hyper but we talked
about that like on the on the show we
kind of got into that stuff and why I
felt what I thought so I don't know I
like I'm gonna be honest like I I
definitely want to shoot more stuff
together and I the pair of nobody saw
coming yeah like I I think you're cool
as [ __ ] so I don't know like I I think
that I watched a lot of videos about
about you on Tick Tock um
people were very like ugly to you
um and I don't think they really see
your personality and they don't
understand that there is a voice every
voice is very important right
everybody's voice it doesn't matter how
what [ __ ] you think their content is you
think they're this their point their
perspective is valid and they are
representing a group of people so you
can't if you care about feelings and you
care about truth then you wouldn't try
to downplay other people's perception
like it's it's valid and there's a lot
of things too that we talk about like
that you talk about with the marriage
and the contracts and disadvantages and
biological things those are things that
just cannot be argued like from a
biological standpoint a lot of stuff it
makes sense so I like what you're doing
personally and I like you as a person
and I think if more people actually sat
down and talked to you they would like
you to
I just might be a tell that tell that to
the beautiful majestic creatures
I'm not saying anything
[Laughter]
um okay guys if you have a question to
submit to Brittany um go on my story I'm
gonna pick a couple right now it's on
Instagram just partly things one they
took away my actual ones I'm gonna let
go okay okay oh this is I looking oily
am I good do you do you think body count
matters
for men or women for women
well if we're talking about this space
that we're in it does matter they like
they're literally using body count as a
way to it's like it's a scale
um of course I'm gonna say no because I
don't want to be judging my body count I
wouldn't judge a man for his body count
um but we're in a world where women are
judged so to a lot of men it does matter
there are some men we don't know the
pretenders whatever there are some men
who don't give [ __ ] so yeah I think
yes and no would you would you agree
that like better marriages like tend to
be formed when they're both urgents or
when the woman's a virgin at least I
would say from this is from my theory
about that is
if you don't know about anything else
there's a greater chance you're gonna
stay so what I've come to realize with
having different types of sex
when you have a big one you know when
it's a small one right you know like and
these things this experience it shapes
how you view what the ideal partner or
guy or sex is like and so if I if I take
the concept of we're both virgins we
both don't know about you can get chokes
get spitting in mouths and anal and all
this crazy stuff sorry but I'm just
saying Hey Y'all spit in each other's
mouths
laughs
you never have no I don't like it though
that's you sorry sorry uh I feel like
yeah you only know of each other so
there's a greater chance like your mind
doesn't necessarily I would I'm not
gonna say it doesn't wander but I would
say that is a the probability is a lot
lower because you don't know anything
that's it you know you don't know what a
you know Lysol cans like because you
ain't never been with your husband's a
five inch he's a six incher okay
do you think you've peaked
and if so what age peaked and what like
yeah look wise do you think you've
peaked physically and if so what age
like when I was in my best shape I mean
obviously I've had a baby now so my my
body's changed I will say that the the
base is still pretty much the same I
feel like my favorite body if I'm
looking back at old pictures
probably
2019 it's probably like I all the
pictures I took then I'm like damn how
old were you 2019 I'm not good at math
what um
sorry I can't even so like two years ago
yeah I feel like that three years three
years ago I'm sorry like I said yeah
um I I feel like
um body wise it's 2019. yeah I feel like
that was my favorite body um because
again I feel like I've always had a
really because genetically I've just
always had a really nice body and I was
always in the gym as well
um but I think I was a lot skinnier in
the 2015 2016 so 2019 was probably like
my favorite and then when do you think
most women Peak
ah
also probably like mid-20s maybe yeah I
mean I like I'm going off of
when I look at the girls I went to high
school with on my Facebook I'm like
she used to be that girl and she's not
that raw now you know not trying to be
mean it's just like they just look a lot
it's honest and it's like you can't
control a lot of it's genetic so unless
you have the money to get like work done
you're going to age it's a natural thing
so I don't even say that to be nasty I
just feel like probably like mid-20s
like 25 26 maybe 25 usually yeah that
would be my guess I I think I actually
think most girls peek at like 19. I
think most of them 19. yeah I really do
they're like still babies I feel like
you're still grown into your body and
stuff
um most girls I know oh and the US got
fat like most girls were in better shape
when they were 19 and I think that's
like half of it okay uh maybe some got a
little better Style by like 21 22 but I
feel like I noticed yeah I think like
19. okay for most girls okay blessing my
thing isn't loading because of the
service can you connect me to the Wi-Fi
for a second
thank you
it's been fun I'm so glad we got to like
talk last thing is top producer
thank you
um guys go to Instagram
um follow it while you're there but for
real submit questions because I'm gonna
have her do them in a second
um okay have you noticed a difference in
dating since you became a single mother
yes
um okay tell me about that do you do you
feel like like that has been the biggest
difference what was bigger the having a
kid or the book the book really
Oh I thought the kid would be bigger
than the book it's a book for sure like
there was a time I'm telling you
at one point the DMS were looking like a
Nike store with all the checks right
after the book must be nice
it was it was quiet I feel like it took
a I don't even really want to say when
it picked back up I don't even know
probably
maybe like eight seven or eight months
after the book it started to kind of
bounce back out but I'm talking it was
and that was how old
I think I was 26 when I released my book
out to 1927. yeah they say the wall the
wall is undefeated it's like 27.
would you date someone like Tate would I
date someone like him yeah could you do
the multiple wives if he was open with
you from the jump
it's like I would want him to myself
um but
I like the way he carries himself I feel
like he has that Mufasa energy and I do
think it's a lot different if you are
it's full transparency I'm never gonna
say never because a lot can happen
between now and never but
I like the idea of someone just being
fully transparent and I don't know
exactly
I don't know if I could be one of
several but I just don't want to say
never I don't know I'm just gonna keep
an open mind so I like transparency I
like honesty I can respect honesty if
you could have a perfect man that you
wanted 666. you know what that means no
I was like what okay six six feet six
inches
um six inches six figures oh my God
all these terms would you would you give
up your career give it my career yeah
for the perfect guy
so I'm just what I'm at home doing
nothing or what am I doing you're being
a mother being a mom kids yeah
I have to have more kids
is that a part of the deal
do I have to offer my uterus or can we
just be in love
um
you don't want to have more kids I don't
know Never Say Never I I again I don't
want to like make
I don't say I never want to have more
kids I would never do this because I
just feel like I've been humbled in a
lot of ways so right now unless a man
wants to marry me why would I have more
kids I already have Maybe daddy you know
like I can't imagine more you know
especially with all that commitment
again if something we get married it
doesn't work out that's a whole you know
whatever but
if what I give up my career
have the perfect guy like he sees the
beauty in the Grand Canyon and Dan like
does the Bachata in the restaurant and
is romantic
I don't know sometimes when you talk
sounds like La La Land respectfully and
just because you'll talk about these
guys and I'm like these men aren't real
dude look man sees the beat let's talk
about the Beauty and the grandkids but
why can't I have a guy that sees the
beauty in the Grand Canyon why why would
I want someone that doesn't see the bee
in the grandkid I can't why can't I have
a millionaire
but he doesn't see the beauty in the
Grand Canyon bro you're gonna be able to
make your own money so why like at the
end of the day you grew up with money no
money why would I even really impressed
but no my point is like it's just
sometimes I think when we talk about
like these perfect guys and it's like it
when I was younger oh God it's so
embarrassing I don't really want to say
it online everyone's gonna roast me but
why would they roast you because it's
embarrassing when I was a kid like oh my
gosh like I totally had like a list of
like what I wanted in my future husband
what's that's not dumb that's really
smart it does but when I read it back I
was like God damn I was delusional no I
I like it I think like God damn I think
for me that I've I'm not looking for
like a [ __ ] perfect guy I just want a
guy that has similar values and yeah
like I don't know how to be to be quite
honest with you like why would a guy see
the value in me if he doesn't even see
the value in this is gonna sound so
crazy I don't care if I say it if you
don't see the beauty in like the world
and the land and all these things why
why the [ __ ] would you think I'm
valuable you
like it's value speak
s so you're not gonna see the value in
me
like so yeah I mean for me I I don't
I don't want a millionaire over someone
who would want to do that with me that's
just where I'm at and I'm okay with that
it's not like I said Grand Canyon is a
big ditch in the higher
the man will see the Grand Canyon like I
just think of my brothers okay and
they're not they're not trying to look
at the Grand Canyon and see the beauty
in it and my dad is I look up to my dad
more than anyone in the world he is a
great he is a great man okay and like I
go to him for like everything and
I he would think it was cool but he's
trying to bike it but that but that to
me no but yeah that's what I'm saying
though like somebody who would want to
bike is someone who would want to hike
like that to me it's not about like oh
wow just the Grand Canyon it's more so
that like I think that's cool him even
wanted a bike is cool to me that's the
kind of guy I would want like I would
love to bike the Grand Canyon with
someone that I love that's like but it's
like see this is where I often like kind
of see where the guys are coming from
because it's like my dad probably would
be looked over by most women when he was
in his 20s he was a little nerdy guy the
University of Chicago shout out dad
shout out
yeah shout out shout out father
um
I already know these comments are
hilarious oh my God can I read you one
it's kind of mean though
that's fine
stop being up
what happened like what she's gonna say
yeah
um okay
oh guys the Tate and the Tate Brittany
Pearl video um it's probably coming out
Friday my thumbnail guy is out of town
this week
um so he's out of town until Thursday so
Friday we're gonna do it
um how did you feel about that
conversation like as a whole
good
um I think I'm saying I think if I had
to do it over again I would have had one
maybe two less people on the panel okay
just because I really wanted to hear you
more and I felt like there was some
people on the panel that just like kept
talking for a very long time yeah and
and I think too I want to clarify
because I like I know that they're gonna
love that video like I love that you
even put that together and thought about
adding me to that
um when I am in a group setting
especially like that that type of panel
I'm an active listener so when
somebody's talking you be quiet you
don't talk so I think that's why for me
when people are going around and there's
three people that have made a point
whatever I had to say I'm just like I
kind of didn't get to say it because
again I believe in just listening and
let people letting people talk and then
when it's my turn to talk I'll talk so I
didn't have a lot of times it was my
turn to talk yeah and when I did I feel
like I kind of had to like hey actually
you know so yeah it wasn't like like and
again I liked a lot of the stuff that we
talked about you know yeah I I think if
I had to do it again but as something
tells me you know there may be uh
another one in the future yeah do you
want to get married
and are you okay would you be okay with
a long-term relationship without
marriage
yes I've actually thought about this
because I would
I don't even think it's really the paper
that I want I think it's just the
commitment and like I would I think I
like the idea of a wedding more than we
have to go sign this and then when we
divorce the courts are in our business
because of like what I'm going through
with the child support custody stuff
um getting out of that contract is going
to be hard right
um so yeah I would be I would want like
still I want to ring still want a
wedding but I wouldn't have to I don't
think we would have to do it like
through the courts yeah it would just be
a commitment to each other and I've like
I said I've actually thought about that
because I think I was watching one of
your videos where a lot of women just
want the celebration the wedding and
they and they don't actually care to get
married
um so yeah I would be open to that would
you be okay with like because I always
said I would be cool with just I want to
say a courthouse wedding okay but you
know I then I'm like you know
if he doesn't want to do the contract
that's fine but yeah I was thinking like
just like a small thing with like my
parents and my family like I I think
that sounds nicer than like this big
like who needs 300 people at a wedding
yeah I don't even know 300 people that
would show up so no I I love the idea of
just like the ceremony and reception and
people just celebrating your your guys's
Union and it doesn't have to be in front
of like I said on paper so that's kind
of where I have changed my views a
little bit where I'm like it's not even
really the contract that I'm wanting
because like whatever who gives a book I
just want you and like all the fun stuff
that comes along with it that you know
sorry I just know how the guys are gonna
see they're like the fun stuff that
comes with it they're like they've been
sold in there
I mean it is what it is but it's like
yeah I mean because it's not just about
like I want to be able again if
especially if I'm marrying someone who
has all of this I've always been open to
prenups like because it's never about
like oh I want to take half of
everything
um even when I was with my ex like we
had talked about prenups like whatever
you know I'm cool with that but I think
that's just where it's like yeah you you
want the the cute stuff that comes with
marriage but I don't even really know if
people actually want to go through the
process especially of getting out of it
I can't even really wanted can I ask you
because
um I was just thinking can I ask you
about child support and like that so
yeah they're saying you have you get 10
000 a month not on child support no I
don't I do not I don't get 200 000 I
don't get ten thousand and right now we
are going through the process of child
support and custody so unless we can
work something out between us we will be
going to trial probably in a few months
right now I'm getting 2 500 a month okay
could you do just like 50 50 custody
with him would he want to do that
because of his career he most likely
would not he'd be awarded that because
he played he's on the road so much
um I'm very open-minded whenever he
wants to see our son and come get him
like he's getting them from the the 29th
to the 7th like because he's traveling
on this two-week period right now so
anytime he wants him I let him see him
like I mean he's I I love PJ that's why
I had a baby with him so despite like
all our [ __ ] that's been out there and
how hard it has been transitioning from
romantic to like basically strangers
that we got a co-parent now
um I still love him I love him to death
you know but um yeah so with the custody
stuff I'm very open-minded I just think
with his career it would be hard for a
judge to like award him 50 50. just
because he travels so much because in my
head like isn't it something that could
be worked out like outside of Court it
is but Hearts Don't Break Even and
he I think in his mind he has a number
which I won't say but he has a number
that he wants to stick to and basically
when you're going through this process
for North Carolina law because it's very
different other places you don't get a
percentage if you both combined to make
a a annually over 300 000 you're
considered off the charts off off grid
so then at this point you have to prove
how much you need in child support So
any bills that my son occupies rent car
note cable groceries those are things
that my son occupies and in Charlotte
um the least amount that I could that I
could get would be 50 of each of those
expenses right the most depending on his
career and what the judge sees fit it
could be up to 97 so whatever bills he
occupies would be covered whatever for
his clothes and diapers and all that and
then that's accumulated in a financial
affidavit is what it's called right and
then you present it to him his team if
he wants to settle outside if he's like
actually no that's too high I don't want
to do that I'd rather try my chances in
court then that's when you go to trial
do you do you think that he would give
you nothing if it was up to him
for the first two months he gave me
nothing
do you think that moving forward he
would continue to
I think he would would just give me
2500.
um you don't think that's I think that's
plenty to raise a kid well when you go
based on the laws for North Carolina
it's all of the bills that my son
occupies so my car note is I think it's
two thousand
um our rent is 27.50
um all these bills so I'm saying it's
those two bills alone are already around
but so this is just like the way the men
are gonna see this is like it's like
you're almost becoming an entitled and
I'm not trying to offend you it's just
like because to me I'm like 2500 a month
Auntie said she could do it on like 200
a month no that's that's fine but in in
reality she doesn't have a baby with an
NBA player right so what also is let me
finish though so what's why it's
entitled it's law it this isn't like my
personal opinion and I've learned
actually a lot about the law in
Charlotte for child support
um my mom got a hundred dollars for me
and uh my brother but again it goes off
based on your income and what the child
would be accustomed to so that's where
all of the the opinions don't [ __ ]
matter because if my son is getting
picked up in a Lamborghini
it's like he has to be in a equivalent
like the judge doesn't want there to be
too big of a gap and that is law so if
people can be upset and feel how they
want but take it up with your judicial
system like this is what it is yeah but
like the whole point is you don't have
to go to court over it now I would like
to settle it outside but that that it I
you can't if I can't let me finish them
go ahead
I have tried to settle this outside and
there's still a chance that we could
right
I'll have given my financial affidavit
they've subpoenaed my stuff they know
what's going all in my business they
know what's going on
it is I do not have the final say okay
so if he doesn't want to settle he does
not have to we can have a judge tell us
who should be awarded what and leave it
up to chance
like I said I wanted to settle from the
very beginning does it matter what I
want because I'm asking him this is what
our bills are this is how much it would
be very reasonable number based on again
you can't lie in the financial affidavit
it's like they subpoena everything so
that's where there's full transparency
it's not like you can get a Chanel bag
with this child support this is
literally to cover your child's needs
this is not alimony people get confused
like 100 000 for a kid like that's it
depends on their lifestyle I'm saying
like this is like this is why the men
like see these laws as unfair and this
is this is why they don't see this as
Fair because I hear 2500 a month and I I
personally think and this is I grew up
in a one percent family okay like this
is I I had the life like sort of we were
like kind of like rich people that like
dressed poor you know what I mean but
but it's like like I hear 2500 a month
I'm like that's plenty for a kid and I'm
not I'm not trying to no that's fine I
don't think it's it's gonna like like
damage a kid if they once in a
Lamborghini once in a Honda Civic but
I'm telling you that's up to judge
that's up to the judge and that's up to
law and again so if you're if you are in
it like I said it's like greater than
equal to so if you're using a 1.6
million dollar house a 500 000 house 400
000 house makes sense like I'm not
saying you have to be 1.6 a million like
that's not what it is so like I said
people are allowed to feel that way I
would love if people were just out of
the business in general the court system
and there was something that could be
worked out but just between families
like that's it but that's again that's a
[ __ ] Ideal World that we don't
[ __ ] live in well and and the
feedback I've gotten from men is a lot
of times like we would get more if we
didn't drag their ass in court
but like this is this is the feedback
like if you just give them time
start like a lot of times you get more
than you think you would have because
most most men want like that I know want
to take care of their kids but it's just
like when a woman because in their head
and to them it's like you're dragging me
to court you're doing all this you're
asking me for all this money and it's
like in their head they're like well
[ __ ] like [ __ ] you no well and to also
yeah
um where that point is not relevant to
me is because he served me I didn't take
this to court he wasn't paying me child
support I had to get a lawyer to figure
out what to do next but he served me
first people don't know that so I got a
paper in the letter in the mail and said
this is what we're about to do he's
taking you to court yes okay I don't
served you so that just means he serves
you yeah so it's not like so for you
saying oh well you know if you didn't
take him to court maybe he would well
he's taking me to court
so again I hear you and maybe for
majority situations that's what it is
but I was served so then I had to retain
a lawyer and like I said all I did was
got a consultation just trying to figure
out he's not paying anything in child
support what do I do and then I got
served so I had a retainer so that's why
I'm saying my situation is like I get it
it's just not uh the typical like yeah
maybe if I was just a little more this
way he would have gave me that no he
served me
I can't really I can't go I have to just
defend myself that's it
so that's where we're at like again
Hearts Don't Break Even people have
their own motives and their own
reasoning to do whatever they do I never
wanted the internet in our [ __ ]
business but when you tweet you was
faking it all along and putting people
in the mix and playing up a narrative
you know people think about me no you
feel like so you feel like he started it
on the internet
when we broke up yes okay okay tell me
tell me about that because when I think
of I like your social media influencer I
just assumed you were first no but
that's why I'm saying nobody really
looks at the facts and really what
unfolded so when we broke up he had
tweeted you were faking it all along and
he said that they were lyrics from a
song
but thousands he got thousands of
retweets and then I became the big bad
gold digging [ __ ] who just used him and
had a baby and bounced on him and then I
became this pedophile
psycho [ __ ] that is just vindictive and
he started it you put the internet in
our business I literally just had a baby
my stitches in my vagina were just
healing why would I want to go to the
internet and have it be some [ __ ]
spectacle for everybody to see that we
broke up why would I want that like
after all the stuff I've learned even
then that doesn't even make it's not
logical and now we have a child my child
has his name
so what do I gain from going back and
forth my baby daddy my son has his name
so why would I want to make him look
stupid and have people in our [ __ ] so
what did you do after the Tweet did you
come and like defend yourself or what no
and that's because I was silent because
that's when all the videos came out yes
so that's what happened because when all
like I'm telling you I've been through
some different things giving birth
how I felt after I don't know it was
just like a crash like hormonally I
don't
I was going through all this stuff and
you just feel like for me I just felt
like I was like
you just wanted to die right
and
when he said that I was like delete the
[ __ ] tweet you know I can't have
deleting it but the damage already been
done all the blogs picked it up all
these stories started circulating
and
I did not tell my story because quite
frankly nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody cares
that I was cheated on nobody cares what
I went through when I was pregnant
nobody [ __ ] cares
so what do I look like going on live
crying about my baby daddy about a
decision I made ultimately right this is
why I picked to be my child's father I
don't need your [ __ ] sympathy and I
don't need your [ __ ] empathy you're
not going to understand even if I even
just this interview right here
may have a better idea but you're still
going to think what you want to think
about me so I for months I was silent
but you know what I did
Helena to being a villain okay well you
guys think I'm a piece of [ __ ] you think
I'm a monster well I'm gonna show you
what a monster really is so then I'm on
Jackson State's campus taking selfies
hide your sons because you guys are
already saying that in my comments
so instead of crying that's kind of
funny I know it was funny it was it was
hilarious I loved it you know so I'm
like let me just laugh at My Pain just
like with you like when people say mean
stuff about you okay this is what it is
this is how I feel you're not going to
use this and hurt me and that is
probably something like so you're almost
like sometimes you're you're trolling
the comments oh yeah absolutely but
people don't know my personality people
think either you're being serious
because they don't because they don't
know my humor they don't know my
personality they don't actually even
know how I cope and I have been on
social media since July of 2012. I have
seen Instagram in its many phases before
there was even videos on there right
I don't know another way
because if you read [ __ ] and you obsess
about it you're crying in the car right
it's I feel like kind of a guinea pig
because I'm one of like the original
Instagram girls right so
I just feel like I don't like to explain
myself to strangers now me and you are
talking where I want you to understand
you're asking me a question I'm telling
you the truth right but to a bunch of
strangers who have no desire to listen
to me as you are I'm not explaining
myself go hide your sons I don't care
you already think I'm this anyways I
can't convince you otherwise and again
I'm not Jehovah's Witness I don't
convert people you ain't a Believer I
ain't here to convert you so yeah a lot
of it is like my personality people
don't really know how I am now now
moving forward
I don't really like to troll as much
because I realize how damaging being
something I'm not a villain how damaging
it has been because that's not my truth
like you've seen me I'm really just a
little sweetie pie that's just kind of
how I am I don't like people to see me
vulnerable and nice and she's actually
likable because I would at one point I
would have rather people fear me
think I'm a succubus evil [ __ ]
because I I didn't want people to see
this mushy part because it's disgusting
right and that's I've always judged that
part but I've told myself I'm gonna
authentically be myself
if it's not as exciting as being a
villain right if I don't get as many
clicks if I don't get any more followers
moving forward today at least I can say
I'm being myself because all that [ __ ]
show that wasn't me being myself that
was me playing into a character that is
like not even a fraction like five
percent of who I am
what do you think about the phrase life
is about choices and trade-offs I agree
I mean I love Kevin Samuels I feel like
that was definitely a message like the
he would preach a lot
and it's true
what did you what was it like meeting
Kevin
and he's a much taller in person and did
you take any of his advice second part
I felt like I started to think about my
life and what I wanted to do moving
forward which kind of I don't say it's
scary I don't want to judge it but like
he talked about a lot of uncomfortable
truths about the perception of men and
like family structure and my situation
and
um it was a lot of difficult truths that
were really hard to hear and I feel like
I started thinking more of a having more
of a business mentality after I spoke to
Kevin and I think he's was very kind I
listened to him a lot when I was
pregnant and I felt like his message
often went missed because they would
sensationalize
um him being hard on women I've heard
him be hard on men I've heard both you
know but the internet's gonna run with
what's the most viral but no I I loved
meeting him he was a fellow Pisces like
myself he's very Charming he's very
funny very open-minded but he he was
tough he was just like tough love so
yeah I miss him you know yeah that's the
one
that's the one and I as I've told you
this but I really wish I could have
interviewed him or I like had him on my
show like that's the one person that I I
just used to watch it's like you watched
him so much he felt like you knew him
absolutely and I'd only talk to him I
think I talked to him twice like once
about my channel and once about an ex
like boyfriend of mine and it was like I
don't know you just like felt like you
knew him even though like I'd only
talked to him twice really yeah and I
think people underestimated how much he
really cared he put a lot of time energy
and effort into talking about family
structures and talk and having people be
accountable and calling out the the I
have a PhD you know die with a dog like
he called out a lot of things that are
gonna be people's realities if they
don't look at their lives now so I think
that's why a lot of his content was rub
people the wrong way my perspective you
know everyone has their own feelings but
because he was necessary he was about
outcomes not really what felt good yep
and a lot of people would like I hate it
when people would like question his
intentions or like you know what I'm
saying like when I'm just like who cares
his outcomes are good he has people
making videos about how they got married
because of him yeah and it's like how
can you argue with outcomes right
um what do you
so did you answer did you take his
advice yeah I've started focusing more
on the business and figuring out like
what do I even like to do like how do I
plan to make money like what is Gonna
Change here like seriously Britney it's
relationship advice that what oh
relationship advice
um
will we talked more about business oh
okay yeah our
like the stuff that we talked about in
like when we would talk on the phone
every now and then um it's funny he
talked to me about business yeah the
first time he was more business so
that's why like when it came to
relationships
we didn't really talk about that stuff
not really to be honest because I just
feel like that I wasn't really focused
on that I was trying to figure out my
life I have a kid now and I feel like he
was you know he was uh really insightful
of that first of that perspective and
topic
so yeah sorry I'm looking at the
questions
what are the pros and cons of only fans
are we talking about like
typically what people post on only fans
are like are these people like posting
like uh let's say like cooking corn
corn to to nudes nudes okay
um
I have
I think it's easy money I don't think
there's gonna be much longevity with it
and
for me
I don't like the idea of selling a
picture of me like a personal picture
that maybe I'd send a guy like like you
can subscribe for like ten dollars and
you can see it and I think it just takes
away
intimacy for me
um
I think it's too invasive but there are
people who obviously make money sex
workers that do can I say that expert
Christmas okay
um sex workers that make bank and they
serve their
like there's an audience for that they
they fulfill their audience's desires
but it's not for me I wouldn't want to
do it no
I I don't like taking the easy way out
either and that's just my opinion I
think it's an easy way out but it's not
like you're not actually asking yourself
what you want to do and you're not
thinking about longevity unless you're
using that money to like
invest in other things but most likely
or not and then not only Now you kind of
have to carry that stigma of
you sell content online and there's guys
that don't care about that but like the
stuff we've been talking about there's
more guys that care that you're an only
fans girl than not so I feel like why do
it if you don't have to you know because
it's just like I feel like it has such a
Mark yeah see we we agree again yeah I
would avoid it I'm like I already got
enough [ __ ] [ __ ] like I can't be
adding now and I just feel like it's
it's an easy way out do you think you
could respect a man and submit to a man
that makes significantly less than you
so forty five thousand dollars a year
yes but it's it's not about the money
that brings the respect it's about the
Mufasa energy and like really caring
about me and respecting me and valuing
me have you ever met a guy that makes
45k a year that has the Mufasa energy
um
the only guy I've I've talked to besides
like my first boyfriend and the lawyer I
don't even
I really haven't had many guys
oh wait I'm trying to think
I talked to a trainer we talked about
that last night yeah what was the
question again could I could you respect
like could you could you submit to him
yeah because I respect what I'm gonna
submit to him that's naturally what I
want to do like I want somebody who's
gonna love him he says he says don't go
don't go out would you would you delete
your Instagram that's my money maker
so if I'm not if I don't care about a
guy's money that means obviously I'm
taking care of like myself and providing
the lifestyle that I want for myself so
I wouldn't delete my money maker now
would you would you go down on lifestyle
for a family
go down in lifestyle what what does that
mean because I provide my own life so
okay so this is this is like often Kevin
Samuels would talk about how women don't
want a husband they want the lifestyle
and you you've kind of agreed with that
a little bit because a lot of people do
want life a lot of people do because
they don't have any earning potential so
and like his point was back in the day
you would work you both would work at
times and you'd have to work twice as
hard just to have children
so it's like you wouldn't you and he
wouldn't make like more money so it
would be like
try not to butcher this too much sorry
Kevin okay but basically okay but so the
whole point is like you don't get to go
on trips you can't go to London for a
week you can't I mean this is different
because you but you see what I'm saying
you don't get to go on trips you don't
get to eat out like even growing up we
even though we're in a one percent
family like I was very much jealous of
some of the lifestyle that some of my
friends lived
um like they would eat out they had
cable like we didn't have cable TV my
parents like I wanted to we still went
on vacations but we never flew and it's
like a lot of times like women would
rather have the lifestyle than a family
well to me what you're describing sounds
like money management because that's you
make money and the reason that your
family has stayed wealthy is because
they don't eat out every night they're
not taking trips here they're everywhere
they are even though you guys could do
that right it's like that sounds like
just money management too they do they
do now I will say oh yeah but that
sounds like money management that sounds
smart so yeah if you have more kids it
doesn't make sense to go out and spend
300 at Outback when you could buy
groceries right but the whole point is
like let's say you deleted your
Instagram tomorrow you you could
hypothetically get a part-time job make
20 000 a year data guy that makes fifty
thousand dollars a year that's 70k you
could live off of that it just wouldn't
be the lifestyle you'd want yeah and so
that's that's the whole question is like
would you go down and lifestyle for a
family because you get a family out of
it and that's like Legacy that's like
what we all want
yeah uh it's like a lot of times as
women we don't want to give up you know
the the Nail's done the hair done the
makeup yeah all of that you know
um Amaya's there's gonna be no because
that's something I can provide for
myself so I would never downgrade My
Lifestyle because again I'm not asking a
man to provide something I can't provide
for myself so again I feel like I'm very
I've gotten so much better at money
management not spending 600 at Sephora
you know what I mean I feel like there's
because I have a son now because I have
to think of money
um and be a lot smarter I have
downgraded My Lifestyle already so to go
from this six figures a year to 20 000
doesn't make sense like I want to tap
into my Fool's potential me tapping into
my fullest potential does not entail
working twenty thousand working a twenty
thousand dollar a year job it just
doesn't that's not what I'm here to do I
wouldn't be given this platform I
wouldn't be giving this voice if I was
if I was meant to have a twenty thousand
dollar a year job that's just what it is
like and I'm just speaking for me like
I'm meant to do this so I just can't
relate to that now
do you think it's possible to find
traditional women in today's world
traditional no no you don't think they
exist uh I want to go looking for one I
would say yeah I'm gonna say no let me
know in the comments where do you find
them yeah I feel like they would
probably have to be like super maybe
super religious
sorry I'm not trying to I'm only reading
the question yeah yeah so but no I I
don't what is your ideal man now
foreign
I'm still figuring that out I feel like
there's like like kind of how we were
talking about off camera as well
I have not liked what I've been
attracting
[Music]
so I'm going into my inner world and
right moving some things around
addressing some [ __ ] answering questions
like even this I don't know I don't know
what to tell you right now there are
things that Within Myself that require
more attention than like what do I want
in a guy like I'm art like it is my
thought process I'm already looking at a
small percentage of men so why am I
gonna dedicate
ideally what I would want in a guy
I'd rather just keep it open like if I
go to the mall and say I want a red
bottom with spiked heel and it has a
pink bow and it has to have this I go to
the mall and the snow would be found
what if I just say I'm gonna black shoe
there's a lot of shoes that are going to
come to me right that I actually like
you know I didn't even know that I
actually like this one better than the
idea of that so that's why I don't have
my list I'm just really big about the
Mufasa energy again what we're talking
about is masculine energy when I say
Mufasa
um he sees my value he wants to
understand me for me and he's honest
those are the only things that I can
think of off the top of my head
character-wise I were talking about so I
don't know what that man looks like he
could be a nerdy whatever guy if he has
those things what if he's gonna what if
he's got Mufasa energy but a beer belly
oh I [ __ ] with him you could Overlook
the beer belly I could if you if he had
everything else I mean like I said
ideally you do want a guy that's in
shape like we talked about earlier in
this conversation yeah but if he had
like all of that he had everything I
wanted just a little beer belly we'll go
to the gym someone said I'll be a
stepdad if she can make me good food can
you cook
can I cook
and can you can you learn if not I can
read instructions you're directions
where should I take Brittany on a date
where yeah oh like yeah if you were to
go if you were to go on a date where
would you go
I would love to just go on a walk I love
going on walks I go on walks with my dog
I love being outside anywhere in nature
would be an ideal day for me we could
have like a picnic I don't know that'd
be fun
do you do you still post thirst traps so
that's are you still thirst trapping
um
I I haven't looked no not really I've
been posting more about my leggings
um and then I do more of like the car
rants
um
no because it's kind of like
okay people actually would prefer to
hear me and I know maybe the guys would
disagree obviously but I get more
engagement on me speaking than me
showing my ass well I was just wondering
if that's changed since like you became
a mom
I don't know if it's necessarily because
I became a mom I just when I started
speaking a lot more people were just
very interested for whatever reason like
it could be because I sounded [ __ ]
delusional whatever or because I was
making sense to some people
um but I just started to notice people
were wanting to hear me talk more even
when I if you go to my page I have
videos where I'm working out people want
to hear me talk I have over a million
views on every video I'm talking in so I
just give people what I feel like they
would like so thirst driving doesn't
have the same potency as it once did
years ago so that's why I don't do it as
much it's just pointless yeah in my
opinion unless you are trying to like
promote an only fans that's what makes
sense but like I don't have that so like
why am I giving you all that I'm gonna
just be in the car talking [ __ ]
do you do you regret doing your book
no
it scared away the people that were not
for me anyways
um it helps my book helped helped a lot
of people and it also most importantly
it helped me because I have lived with
shame my entire life
the book helped release some of that but
I think even yesterday when we talked
about some stuff some more shame came up
right so this is like a layer by layer
thing that I've been dealing with my
whole life
so I I don't regret it it was a big step
I actually fired my manager
the day I posted it because he said
you're going to ruin your life
if you post that book you're going to
lose all your brand deals nobody's gonna
like you
and I've hired them and I'm like well if
it can be destroyed by the truth like if
my truth makes me undesirable
then I would rather just be seen as
undesirable then I don't want to live a
lie and act like I'm some you know this
little princess that's never done
anything I swear that's not my truth so
that's why I'm very big on I accept what
comes behind what I've done because I
don't want to live a lie I don't want to
live a lot I want to be authentic I want
to be myself
take me as I am or have nothing at all
see this is just me thinking out loud I
feel like it could still be the truth
but the truth that you don't tell
everyone you know what I mean yeah
because in my head I'm just like I don't
necessarily like I feel like some guys
would have been even with all this stuff
if everyone didn't have to know yeah
like they would still look past it but
it's like when you put that out there a
good guy that maybe would have taken you
seriously then like wouldn't you know
yeah I mean I feel like because a lot of
times we'll say things like oh if he was
like the right person he would just look
past it but like I'll use myself in this
example so it's not like personal right
but if if there is I think ideally like
when I wanted to wait till I was married
to have sex right and if I if I stayed a
virgin like there are guys that would
have looked at me then that like
wouldn't now because I'm not and a lot
of times like the people's immediately
reaction is like well you could still
find a guy even though you're not ever
okay that's fine that's fine but there's
still a pool of men that like would
probably eliminate me now does that make
sense no I I absolutely understand that
I'm not saying that there weren't like
good guys that may have been interested
yeah um but again this this is my truth
and it's like if the dog my grandma
always used to say if the dog wouldn't
have stopped to [ __ ] he would have
caught the rabbit so it's like I I I
although it's like okay we could
entertain that yeah it just isn't
Progressive for me because again this is
my truth like I have considered like
maybe I don't write another one not
because I'm like I'm so fearful book
number two if you do absolutely yeah
absolutely no and I'm gonna and you know
what no yeah you wouldn't be in there
because I feel like even meeting you and
having this conversation and getting to
to pick Andrew's brain as well like I
learned a lot and that's what I I really
pride myself on is being able to sit
down with anyone and learning and
learning from everyone so that's why I
think now I do view it a little
differently I don't know how I feel
about another book people have been
asking for one
I don't know I'm just not I I don't feel
called to do that right now at this
point I only support it if I get a
chapter
if you do like Pearls of Wisdom I
was talking talk about all the all the
wisdom
you definitely need to use that for your
show Pearls of Wisdom I love that
someone said it should be Eclipse
Channel it should absolutely no yeah and
I was like I was like what should we
make Pearls of Wisdom pearls wins the
merch yeah yeah I would love that that
would be so well I don't know
um
sorry guys I'm looking at your questions
let me see some in the chat
let me know some oil am I good so I'm
awesome
okay okay I'm once said write a
children's book
oh that would be cool
um yeah they said would you date someone
like you I'm gonna give you like one
maybe two more questions okay
like it's not oily oh what's more
important loving someone or security
loving someone
because I it goes back to what if he was
a bum
remember Mom like no job look at men no
job look at men love us with no jobs
men love us I don't know why they take
all night security work blessing
sorry I won't do you like that
they'll genuinely love us no job you
could just be not oh I'm so happy to see
you but they but they are they have but
they have to work still so like they're
still providing the lifestyle right so
hell no I'm not gonna no it's just
that's what this is what Kevin Samuels
would say that's what the men do when
they make up a lot of money they know
they gotta marry a bum they got someone
that don't it like I said a lower paying
job but not just kidding I'm just
kidding but not no job because no job is
like why not what about McDonald's
like the manager like the region manager
I was trying to make it better so I'm
trying to make it better Brittany
what oh
yeah flipping burgers
don't worry he got a raise from 12 to 15
and up I'm gonna need my honey bunch to
try harder I can't he's gotta aim higher
than me but he's jacked he's in the gym
I see what you're trying to do and I
just cannot no look at it look it so so
that's your option that's option one you
love him he's the smooth talker you know
the type they make us all fall in love
absolutely then you forget their bums so
so because they had to have the time to
learn how to talk absolutely guys with
jobs they don't know they don't have
time for this right so you you really
love him you know how to talk make you
feel nice whatever but he flips burgers
for twelve dollars an hour however this
was a really you could also hypothetical
you could also that's why it's fun you
could also
to visualize it he's also jacked his
stuff now the the old guy let's say
so you're 30. let's make him 57.
I like to be exact 57.
with the beer belly you're not really
attracted to him but but
you're not even worried about child
support this man's so rich you're not
even been worried you don't even you are
chilling in the you got the car the see
and you had both and you left for some
cheating respectfully but now these are
your options because learning the wall
has come
you're Walling
I am Walling right now
um that neither one sounds appealing no
you gotta pick one oh my God so I don't
understand you'd rather die alone than
do that I'd rather I understand but now
okay there's a gun to your head you have
to pick the man
and man number two works a lot he's
driven he's so driven
you know
but I'm not that attracted to him no
it's a little simpy
I like a little stinky okay uh she's
smiling she's thinking about security
she's thinking about it she's thinking
about it
so which one really loves me though
they both really love you oh [ __ ] yeah
you gotta pick one
oh I feel like a part of me is like
shallow in once
once the guy like I I wanna I don't know
I feel like it's where I'm a little
shallow with looks the hot guy
the phone we call that the guy at the
foam Cannon party what does that mean oh
Cal explain see we shout out shout out
roller tomasi oh man so so the guy at
the foam Cannon party is like the guy
that women sleep with right away but
he's like they don't look at his long
term so they sleep with him quicker
where the guy they feel like they could
lock down like makes him they make me
jump through hoops right because like
the the first one they have like the
animal more like genuine desire for yeah
and they're like oh she said you don't
have a job
yeah I I feel like that's that's my God
to honest truth like I would rather date
the trainer or date the guy in
McDonald's
that loves me because I just I can't
that's basically like a sugar daddy and
if I if I wanted a sugar daddy I would
got one years ago
like I don't want one now just because
the options are changed no because it
still is like I mean I don't know I get
it because he has money it's not
technically aiming low but it's like
[Music]
I don't know I feel like both could use
work one like let's get you a different
job and then even the older guy let's
get you in the gym this is what the men
want us to know this isn't Bill demand
this isn't build a bum you can't hold
men yeah
yeah that's why I feel like a lot of us
women if you know we we don't want to we
have to if we don't want the bun we
don't want the beer belly we're gonna
die alone oh I got a question can you
turn a hoe into a house worth
if the hoe and I put that in your
clothes on purpose oh
if the hoe wants to be a wife it has to
be her she has to want that in her heart
because you can't make someone be
something they don't want to be so yeah
like I I no like I feel like you'd have
to want that I don't think a guy can
make you beat up
I mean
you still have to would be even if he
was like willing to maybe show you the
ropes and teach you you'd still have to
you'd have to be the first person that
wants that and I think there was a
couple that you had used last night
um I can't remember the couple but you
had said I think you're talking about
Kim okay Kim and Kanye yeah yeah you're
talking about them
I don't really think she cares about
being someone's wife
no so if she doesn't care about being
someone's wife
then she's not gonna be away so you
can't change that so that's why my
answer is you can't make someone be they
don't you cannot make them be what they
do not want to be that's what my dad
always would tell me like he would
always say to let Pete like the biggest
mistakes people make is trying to
control people and make them into
something they're not and like people
are who they are yeah yeah and that's
what you know that's why I said you were
the least delusional one on that planet
I think sometimes your idea of love is
like La La Land yeah you know and I I
think you know
um as women we've been sold a dream but
you know I think you took more
responsibility more than the other girls
on those panels I think that's like the
first step right you have to admit and
you have to own your truth so it may not
be like I said there's a lot of harsh
realities with my truth but that's okay
I'm in my truth
whatever is meant to happen it's gonna
happen well thank you for sitting down
with me thank you for having me
um tell them where to find you any
social media you want to plug I do uh
you can find me on Tick Tock because I'm
tic-tac-toeing now
um at the Brittany Renner you can find
me on Instagram at bundle of Brittany
I'm going to be doing more on my YouTube
channel so it's Brittany Renner with two
r's or else Twitter Brittany Renner with
two r's and I am gonna be doing my own
show
um in 2023 so be on the lookout for that
and um yeah I'm excited thank you for
having me thanks for coming
um also I'm look for me in her new book
I
want nothing but good things absolutely
I want it to be just like oh yeah
virtuous amazing woman yeah that's
that's I like that one
okay guys
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel let me know I
want to do more of these sit-down
interviews I'm trying to do more
one-on-one stuff so let me know who you
want to see me interview also
everyone's asking about the video being
released I said this earlier but Friday
likely likely Friday
um on top of that
I'm not I'm going home for like a month
so I won't have shows for December
and like half of January I'll post when
I know exactly when I'm coming back
in the meantime at the same time I
usually do my show Auntie Jenny and King
riches is going to be doing their show
so make sure you guys subscribe to both
of their channels um and go watch there
we are you know we are here managing
Talent which is great so like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel